we had a few quieter days on Donald
Trump's Twitter and then Trump exploded
with a series of unhinged tweets the
strangest of which were allegations that
former President Barack Obama had
trumped our offices quote wiretapped
during the 2016 election Trump presented
no evidence for this but the timing of
the tweet was not long after propaganda
news website Breitbart published an
article making basically the same
allegations here's the tweets that
Donald Trump sent starting with terrible
just found out that Obama had my wires
tapped in drum tower just before the
victory nothing found this is
McCarthyism of course it's not
McCarthyism has nothing to do with
McCarthyism continuing was Trump quote
is it legal for a sitting president to
be quote wiretapping a race for
president prior to an election turned
down by court earlier a new low Trump
continued I'd bet a good lawyer could
make a great case out of the fact that
President Obama was tapping my phones in
October just prior to election and
wrapping up this tweet storm with how
low has President Obama gone to tap with
a double P that's like a super tack ta P
would be he tapped the phones ta P P is
like wow that's serious tapping to tap
my phone's during the very sacred
election process this is Nixon Watergate
bad or sick guy there's definitely
something going on right now that's
similar to Nixon Watergate but I don't
think it has anything to do with
President Obama so sometimes it makes
sense just to laugh sometimes it makes
sense to laugh and cry sometimes it
makes sense to actually try to explain
what's implied here number one the an
Obama spokesperson who spoke out about
this pointed out that not only is this
not true as far as they know but that
the White House and Obama don't order
surveillance on individual people that
those are decisions made by the Justice
Department presidents don't order
wiretaps period but let's explore right
if indeed a so called wiretap was
ordered of Trump Tower how it would have
happened tells us a lot about what it
mean US law says that in order to order
a wiretap the Justice Department would
have to go to a federal court and
demonstrate that there's probable cause
that one of two things is true either
number one the target of surveillance is
an agent of a foreign power or there's
reasonable there's probable cause to
believe that the target of the
surveillance has committed a major crime
this means that if it is true Pat that
Trump Tower was under surveillance by
federal authorities a judge was at some
point presented with compelling evidence
pointing to probable cause that Trump
either was an agent of a foreign power
we can imagine what power that would be
or that had he had committed a crime or
someone in his organization campaign
administration and that would mean that
Donald Trump if the allegation is true
and so far we've not heard evidence
suggesting that he's that it's true if
Trump was wire tapped by the Obama
Justice Department that you may have the
best evidence so far that Donald Trump
was really into something bad yeah and
you can tell he's definitely trying to
go on the offense here anytime that
Trump is backed up against the wall on a
media story he'll just make up a new
media story of his own this time the
distraction if true is really damning
about what it is that the Justice
Department hypothetically suspect the
Trump of having done there's another
layer to this though that's endlessly
fascinating which is remember Donald
Trump's recent CPAC speech where he said
in no uncertain terms that anonymous
sources should not be allowed in media
period it was insane then when he said
it and we exposed why as well as Trump's
hypocrisy but consider this Thursday
night right-wing radio talk-show host
Mark Levin made allegations about this
unsourced allegations write anonymous
anonymously sourced non source
allegations the next day Breitbart
picked up the story that Trump might
have seen which caused the tweet storm
and Breitbart cited heat street as a
source for the entire Obama wiretapped
Trump thing if you look at the heat
street article it uses anonymous sources
which Donald Trump opposes but is now
parroting from anonymous sources there
are three
possibilities here folks okay number one
there was no wiretap and Trump made it
up okay number two there was an illegal
wiretap somehow the Obama
administration's circumvented the legal
process and put a wiretap in place of
Trump Tower possibility number three is
there was a wiretap it was legal which
means that something very suspicious was
being done by the Donald Trump campaign
if it is true that there was a wiretap
Trump is president could declassify it
the president has the power to
declassify whatever they want
show us the documents and prove that
there was a wiretap I think it's
essentially made up I mean I don't think
he has an inside scoop on this I think
he just heard the Mark Levin take on and
I think he saw the Breitbart article and
ran with it but I mean if you're the guy
that is at the forefront of combating
fake news yeah you have to have some
credibility within the claims that you
make sure clearly he doesn't have any
here because he's not providing any
evidence maybe this is good strategy
though because Trump got his foothold in
politics by just saying Oh Obama wasn't
born in the US the birth certificate is
bogus and that actually initially was
sort of like his first stepping stone
into people saying hey I kind of like
Trump as a politician maybe this is
another way to improve his standing by
saying Obama wiretapped me even if it
makes no sense even if there's no
evidence they seem to be getting along
so well together Trump and Obama I mean
they were putting on a good face at
least for a while yeah they were we'll
follow it we'll see what happens